[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 moment house dot com slash tiny
meat gang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.com
tiny meat gang let's do some tick tocks
you wanna you wanna let's just make some
tickets yeah you wanna do something no
let's do some producer surprise
honestly i better say you could also get
scared by tick tocks if you want
scared ex what scared me oh
i'm just surprised it is nighttime it is
nice
night time on earth on earth yeah okay
producer's surprise let's do it
let's go i'm stoked we haven't done this
impressive like we could do a scary one
and then it's just like cody noel
oh that was so pretty wait for it
i [ __ ] hate that voice oh my god oh
my god oh my god
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
it's silent dude that went in the
building
you can hear the the unit was empty
thankfully the unit was empty ripped to
this car
holy [ __ ] how did they [ __ ] that up my
brother came
we watched it one more time i got here
over to watch the fireworks
in dtla
oh that was so pretty wait for it
oh my god oh my god oh my god
i mean i feel like that's fake
dude that went in the building i don't
think so man
yeah i don't think so man how did they
[ __ ] that up
uh driving precision driving precision
wow why are you even allowed to do
fireworks in downtown l.a you're not
you're not so someone just
really in downtown yeah
why risk that dude i don't even think
you realize how many fireworks were
going off in la
on the fourth of july really it's not a
war zone
oh dude but it's not legal here right
absolutely not damn we didn't hear a
single one in tahoe
dude it was like the entire city was lit
up huh
it near my place they were going to like
two in the morning ugh damn your dog's
just freaking the [ __ ] out
oh yeah we're getting benadryl
eventually he chilled out but in the
beginning he was like he's definitely
bugging
um one bugging that bad though i
actually just put him in my office and
started a twitch stream and you know put
him in my office with a
a bunch of uh roman candles yeah yeah
in the office and he definitely he's not
crying anymore
just you know kind of train him out of
it yeah
yeah no i just did a 10 out i've
actually been training for this day
because
leading up to 4th of july i would just
go to sleep with 10 hours of roman
candles
sleep mix yeah
what else we got that [ __ ] is crazy man
what is this what in the hell oh yeah
all right i already know
yeah we know this one that's funny
what the [ __ ] yeah that's good yeah this
one's kind of
did you see the video those two dudes in
like the walmart or whatever
slapping that guy nah and then one guy
hits him on the head
on the top of the head it's so funny
i'm not gonna send it though yeah it's
fine you just have to take my word for
it
i believe you yeah there's there was a
funny tick tock talking about tick tocks
is kind of like talking about dreams
yeah it is like you don't really know
yeah exactly you can't verify you won't
have to this one was so crazy
yeah oh do you see that tick tock of
that a girl scissoring a whale
yeah yeah i don't know i can't find the
link but it's definitely real
it's a hundred percent real
[Music]
uh what else
oh you got cream what
do it with milk oh you gotta dodge it
like the little boxing training thing
oh you got creamed no
no no i hate that one i hate that one
that's awesome that's how i was playing
the game and today i'm going to attempt
the world record for the fastest time to
make a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
so
here we go
and she eats it all too oh my god bro
my guy isn't even fast though nah you
want to see the nastiest
tick tock nine you want to see the
i'm gonna [ __ ] man
this is the most
my god this is wildly uncomfortable but
i just
don't get why we i don't even know if
we'll be able to keep this bit
take a note take a note
risky bit of the of the night
get ready bro i don't think you're ready
for this [ __ ]
and go
what is this cubing
wait what what the [ __ ]
do you see him yeah he's got a boner
right
cubing sauce moments dude this is the
most famous cubing sauce moment of all
time
damn dude he's really i mean he's
excited
that's the new fail army of sus moments
yeah
no cue just cubing sauce moments
there's so many man but this one's my
favorite
like are there more than ten there's
like a hundred it's like thousands man
keeping sauce moments that's like when
connor was like had half wood at the
mayweather weigh-in
it's so crazy too this
that means this kid is an animal for the
cube oh yeah oh yeah
like when he looks at that that's like
when like israel out of sonia lost and
the thing is
he still gets more box than
sae racing yeah he's seriously way more
boxed than that
racing team kid deals with boxes all day
every day yeah
[Laughter]
yo sae ra formula sae this is what it
looks like to actually get [ __ ]
damn bro he like he's looking at that
cube like he smells blood
let let it play again you know never
mind the boner part like look at that
look look at that his jaw is twitching
like how in he's that's unreal
how fast do you do that um
harder than the cubes
harder than the cube man he's [ __ ]
stoked
it's just so crazy you know how many
times i saw that in diving
oh i'm kidding i'm kidding just dudes
winning diving matches and speedos yeah
[ __ ] yeah let's go get out the water
hardest yeah yeah
it's just crazy to me like he just
arranged some colors and got
rock solid man
like it wasn't even like
i believe this someone's just writing
numbers in a box
nine seven three four four four five i
completed it
nah i i believe that cause you could be
stuck in this
like when i see someone doing sudoku on
an airplane i'm like they've been trying
to do that for like months yeah
they've been trying to solve that same
page for almost a year
yeah true so i could i could imagine
like writing it in finally you get
like bricked up
that's me whenever i get out of a
go-kart
hey man fast laugh
that was me at the surf ranch too yeah
man i think you left your phone in your
races
nice wave nice wave man what's up with
your wetsuit
it's like a little nub
i think there's like a rock in there or
something
there's something like poking through
i'm not sure what that is
[Laughter]
your suit's just barely more than normal
looking out man these are the top cubing
suspense
that guy's voice everyone knows this
clip as a top cubing susma man
what they do not realize is being sucks
on the cube is more common than
you think [ __ ] you know all right go
next go next
oh damn it sounded like a dj set
honestly yeah
that could be a dream and i like dogs
[Laughter]
also you got a little producer surprise
man i'm having fun right now
and you weren't before no
bro what is that you make
what is that yeah does that he make aloe
vera she's
jerking that thing off i didn't realize
it was just like well that's why it's
made
a giant praying mantis come if that's
how it's made i'm making aloe vera all
the time yeah
sorry homemade praying mantis come
yeah it looks like a giant bright mantis
dude do praying mantis
come yeah dude
everyone comes is it i mean there's just
such like
you know hard creatures i don't picture
them
with any kind of like liquid inside of
their body you know that's how do you
think you get hard
okay
um what nothing i was just
looking into the lens you might have to
cut this last three minutes i'm
delirious
why i don't know i'm so [ __ ] tired
that's why i'm having so much fun all
right fair fair play to him
[Music]
i don't know i thought or there's some
generator online i think that you can
use
yeah i thought someone uploaded like a
parody like a tutorial on how to do it
i beat the sweat off as nuts
[Music]
vertical end of the horizontal
double per se what the [ __ ] i don't know
this is one of those i don't know you
understand that
bro what
[Music]
this is that prank man what is happening
[Music]
official arm wrestling they're just
trying to arm wrestle
torque
do you ever look at [ __ ] like this and
you're like you just get emasculated
watching it
what well you watched like that [ __ ]
you're like yeah i would die and
yeah exactly year one thousand snapped
around the other way
if this was year one thousand i would be
dead yeah yeah yeah
i would be out last night i would be a
textile merchant
yeah i would have nothing to do with
[ __ ] physical combat
all right guys i think that's it